these days I'm thinking and animating
about messages we cannot read uncracked
codes if you will
apparently this topics in the air what
with the release of the imitation game
this month that films about Alan Turing
and cryptanalysis of those German Enigma
machines during World War two
I say cryptanalysis and not cryptography
a word you may know better because
cryptography is about sending a message
securely by changing it often changing
it so it looks meaningless this is
obviously useful when there's a way for
the receiver to change it back and see
the original message crypt analysis on
the other hand works out ways to
understand and break those systems to
understand how the message is being
changed by the system so that you an
intended recipient with your prying eyes
can read the original message but this
is all my brother's field I should grab
him and you two can chat about it
sometime it's all separate from
decipherment which is an attempt to
recover messages in an unknown writing
system crypt analysis works with texts
that were meant to elude you
decipherment works with messages that
were once plainly readable but aren't
anymore thanks to accidents of history
so as you'll see in next Friday's video
which contains both hidden codes often
use characters we recognize to hide a
secret message undeciphered scripts have
characters we can't even read or
identify that stand between us and not
so secret or not intentionally secret
message of course there is that pesky
Voynich manuscript which may be both
with all this in mind you've got a bit
of background to appreciate next week's
video I'd like to take the time to
welcome all new subscribers you're
making it so much fun to talk about
language here big smiles for all of you
and let me know in the comments if
you're interested in continuing this
topic with the short series that looks
deeper at the decipherment of writing
systems like egyptian and maya